okay sir here we are where's the sliders
there are no sliders sir we are not at a
chain restaurant we are at a
psychologists office
yes no sir sit down listen sit down Mike
okay okay sir people are saying you are
mentally unfit for the office and we
both know that's not true
I'm incredibly mentally fit my doctor
said I had the most neurons of any
person he had ever met I wish I mean our
us oh you know what you can talk about
yourself the entire time yeah Anna you
talk about yourself
I'm totally sane and I'm the President
of the United States mr. Trump I feel I
need to disclose to you that I'm the
founder of an organization called duty
to warn I don't care well I think you
should know that our Association
advocates your removal under the 25th
amendment because we believe you're not
psychologically fit wrong well totally
wrong you make a lot of grandiose and
paranoid sounding statements like you
had the biggest new operation crowd oh
yeah
and that Barack Obama bugged your
offices he's spying on everybody so
here's my question do you really believe
those things you say no yes did I get it
right it seems like you have an unusual
need for approval people must see Trump
everywhere because I grew up in Queens
and then we went into Manhattan everyone
else had men and was rich and they went
to the parties we went to studio 54 and
they did coke off a twig he's asshole
I didn't get to do any of that I had to
go to studio 54 and stand on the line
one time I met Andy Warhol and I thought
that he was just a sheepskin rug I was
always left out a doughy boyfriend
Queens with big juicy kissy lips well
I'm glad you can own some of that
insecurity is it okay that I've been
farting in this cell for the whole time
well that's okay let's move on yeah tell
me a little about your mother mommy had
the best chair
toughest air you could throw a rock at
it it would bounce right off she was a
tough woman very tough but what are we
doing when we're hiding from mummy
you know when moms out of the key food
and I'm around the corner trying to get
my PUD yanked by whatever girl I went to
school with and some alley and then you
come home and you see mommy and ago I
did a dirty thing and mommy can't no and
I control mommy then it does seem like
control is a large part of this I'm not
gonna change say that that might be part
of the problem I'm a tough guy and my
father was a tough guy you know tell me
more about that
the guy was so tough he used to say you
gotta be a killer in order to be king
you gotta be a killer
we got a bit of team you got to be
Italian you gotta Bennett ain't gotta be
the tailor tape I know daddy I know
daddy I know I need to
[Music]
what's wrong with you I felt something
mister where did you just go just now
my dad was saying I'm the killer in the
king and then I pinched myself to feel
pain
look mr. Trump I really need to confront
you with a few things I don't see that
you really have control over your
impulses wrong I think you suffer from
3d serious personality disorders a
narcissistic Oh me anti-social shut up
and paranoid who told you
and to make matters worse I think you
have grandiose and persecutory delusions
are you saying that my behavior is out
of my own control because I'm so
divorced from my own personality
exactly so that means I'm not
responsible for what I do
no that's nice doc that's perfect
diagnosis check will be in the mail Yeah
right I'm crazy crazy it's not my fault
I nuts come back responsible for what I
do serve this lady give me a groceries
out sir please I'm not so crazy okay
give me a little bunny give me a bunny
child care bunny hey lady
I lost my mind wow I'm crazy I love it
whoa wait
[Music]
he's got lazy I'm changing